d4 Knight f6 played a bit of a late
start of the video against guy fox from
the US and it's one of those guys with
the bank of gambit you should be sure
now there's more than one move I also i
also had to try this before okay so
let's prepare your form yeah that was a
quick at least what's black set up
probably five young okay let's get the
cat at the King on the on the queenside
and see how he fails at this maneuvering
position that's very closed I expect
yeah exactly this move and now we have a
completely closed position with the
maneuvering game and frankly speaking
quite a number of people who play earth
the bangko are not used to slow
maneuvering games
the night on h4 is not better placed
that covers f5 so that the f5 porn break
is some not so easy to accomplish and I
need to regroup my pieces anyway the d2
night maybe two III or something yeah
III Islamic bad square let's try for
that and if the circumstances are a riot
for that I can also think about playing
f4 yep not sure what this is doing no
you know just bolstering the center it's
not it not strictly necessary but a
decent move so f5 you are not going to
claim your e this is exactly the moment
why they do play it but in this case and
I cannot really believe that like it's
coming with with that five okay that's
it's not like em I have some substantial
add she also it's just a slow
maneuvering type of game
uh-huh okay so he doesn't mind that we
exchanged his bishops it still has his
good bishop so I don't mind the trade as
well as course so and yet still cannot
play a five I can I wonder Knight g4 the
Queen s is not doesn't have many squares
but I cannot it's not them it's another
possible travel or anything well that's
how to trap something that you cannot
attack you okay so just get the ropes
over
hmm
somehow the screen placement I know is
there some way to amuse it still does
this f5 but I'm having at five I cannot
really believe that this is good I can
take we should be two or so I don't know
it did it feels like he's weakening his
own position yeah still let's do that I
for sweet but he cannot really put a
night or someone night on that Bishop f4
I can do night hg2 and then H for this
is the general idea anyway repin sorry
I'm threatening age for a g5 by the way
so he needed to react them and in some
way yeah this is in case of further f5
sin so that I have f4 and the dome
diagonal opens so just 92 92 I know f4
f5 is really and they cannot do that so
let's go beyond age 4
f5 no g5 so no way he is going to going
to play that now maybe get night on on
g3 of course the position is quite
closed so it might happen that it looks
nice but it it simply is not open open
enough to make any substantial progress
but 9393 take that i can just take that
if you place g5 it open up it opens up
the long diagonal for my for my bishop
well II five yeah that's going a five
take 1995 you can play well not really
okay so 95f Bishop g7 hmm
it's still not so terrible for black
yeah I've a manager up gh1 and 92 it
would be nice night d to e forms would
be immensely helpful
rupee to maybe I can play rock age seven
if he goes Rudi to I thought rook age 70
maybe what the Sun I it's all check
hands all check 92
jesus what a position this is just the
exchange yeah I lost the thread IAM
check time morning not just be giving
have ft seven hours i'm not i blundered
this but half g sevens was lucky yeah
yeah i wanna hit this red wrong this go
long yeah this is a sort of nervous
let's move I think it's not necessary at
all to take thinking of it I can just
cover I don't need to do this now just
or d 6 or something at plus-7 according
to pump yeah yeah this must be great
with this bishop but there is always
always so complicated yeah thanks for
watching